in my main video I mentioned something
called the shortest split line method I
really had to zoom past that because of
time constraints but it's a very
interesting way of dividing up voters
into boundaries into different districts
so I wanted to spend a little bit more
time going into depth with it here so
this is the sample population I used in
the main gerrymandering video there
about 40 voters here and I want to
divide them up into eight different
groups now when you have an easy number
it's a pretty simple thing to do you
find the line that divides them into two
equally populous groups and use the
shortest line if you have multiple lines
that will do the same thing there are 20
voters on the left and there's 20 voters
on the right then you take each of those
two groups and you do the same thing
again you find the shortest line that
will divide the two populations into
equal sized groups so now there's 10 in
each group and ultimately we want eight
voting ranges here so we divide them one
more time
then you end up with eight equally sized
ranges each with five votes and that's
the basics of the shortest split line
method just always use the shortest line
you can to divide the two groups but the
question that naturally comes up is what
if you have an odd number of districts
you want to divide them into seven
groups instead of into eight groups this
is where the cleverness of the shortest
split line method comes up is if you
take 7 divided by 2 you don't get a
round number you get 3.5 but what you do
is you take that 3.5 and you round it up
to get 4 and down to get 3 and this
tells you the ratio that you want to
draw the line app for the population so
you want to draw a line that divides the
population into a 4:3 ratio for every 4
voters in one group you want 3 voters in
the other group so as best I can tell
this is the shortest line that will
divide this population of voters into a
4:3 ratio unless there's double check
there's 24 voters on the left there are
18 voters on the right 24 divided by 18
gives us 1 point 3 and 4 divided by 3
gives us 1 point 3 we've drawn this line
in the right spot the next step is to
take that ratio that 4:3 ratio and that
actually tells you how many districts
you then want to divide each of these
separate groups into so on the left hand
side we want to take that group of
voters and divide them into four equally
sized groups now that's really easy to
do because we have an even number so we
find the shortest line to divide them
into two equal sized groups and then do
it once again
now we have our four groups on the Left
each of which has six voters inside of
it now to divide up the group that's on
the right we do the same thing that we
did with the number seven take three
divided by two you get one point five
round one point five up you get to
around one point five down you get one
so we want to divide that group into a
2:1 ratio finding the shortest line that
will do that should be this line we can
just double-check our math again there
are 12 voters in the top six voters in
the bottom 12 divided by 6 gives us 2 2
divided by 1 gives us 2 so we know we've
drawn that line in the correct spot and
again that ratio tells us how many
districts we actually want to draw among
these remaining areas so that bottom one
is 1 we're done there right that has six
voters there's nothing more to do with
that bottom district the district that's
two it's an even number so that's easy
we want to make two districts out of
here just divide it in half
there's the shortest line that will give
us 6 voters on each side and now at the
end of that method we have 7 equally
populous districts that were drawn with
the shortest lines possible to create
those districts if you're interested in
this and other stuff relating to
electoral fairness I highly recommend
you go to range voting org they're the
group that as far as I can tell came up
with a split line method and they have a
lot of really interesting information
there such as maps of all of the states
in America drawn using this method and
comparing them to the districts that
currently exist thank you very much for
watching